and one funny anecdote I'll say is that
over the years people have said things
about arcane like you know we try to
hire some guy and at the end of the day
passes on us and he goes somewhere else
we asked like you know this is uncommon
most people that come applied to say
they really want to work there because
they know what kind of game we make but
once in a while we have someone pass on
us and and often when we ask them why
you know this is like going back ten
years whatever like why why didn't you
take the job and they often would say
you know I'm gonna go with ei or whoever
because Midway because I feel I need the
stability of a big company and like
archeins been around 17 years and very
seldom have we laid anybody off I don't
think we've ever had layoffs in that
sense you know and big companies are
just like you know for a while it was
like every six months mass layoffs or a
closure of a studio in this state or
that state and it's like I think you
really should think through that whole
thing about stability and games and like
who's really stable and who's not stable
you've probably heard of arcane studios
in 2012 the team entered the spotlight
with Dishonored a game lauded for its
fluid blend of stealth action
first-person mechanics and the
progression of a role-playing game 2016
saw the release of Dishonored 2 a sequel
that took the ideas established in its
predecessor and expanded them in nearly
every way it garnered similar critical
praise and further developed our Kane's
particular style of game and of course
just recently arcane released prey and
despite its Syfy aesthetic it displays
the same tenets of the dishonored series
experimentation improvisation and player
choice but despite our Cain's recent
success it wasn't always a household
name in fact for most of its history it
toiled in relative obscurity its first
two games arks fate Alice and Dark
Messiah of Might and Magic were well
received but result in lackluster sales
then came a string of promising titles
that were later canceled returned to
Raven home and expansion for half-life 2
lMNO the narrative focus project with
Steven Spielberg and the Crossing genre
blending game much like the ones arcane
would later become known for and all of
this begs the question why did it take
12 years for the studio to find success
how did so much Palin go unrecognized
for so long what is it about dishonour
that finally gave arcane its time in the
limelight
[Music]
it's this story that brought us here to
Austin Texas a bastion for all things
weird in a way sis of ideas in a desert
of tradition it was here where raphaël
colantonio opened our canes second
branch in 2006 with the intent of
tapping into the city's development
talent it is it is still a little
shocking in a way because I think I
think some some studios maybe are
immediately successful we want to gain
and they go big or you know they have
like a lot of funding so they arrive and
they they hire like a big team and so
that's not our case we started four
people were very broke for a long time
our first game was kind of known in the
fans community for this kind of game but
it was not successful financially so it
was it was a long struggle like
everywhere we would go at least three or
anywhere nobody would know us ever and
occasionally I would you know people
with good interest myself and people
stay away from a I would say Arcana
occasionally one would say oh yeah yeah
but even when they said that I was not
sure that it was it was sincere and I've
been actually it arcane now longer than
any other job I've had in my entire life
I think I've been at arcane over eight
years now and I when I realized that I
was like wow that's longer than I was in
the Air Force is longer than I've had
any job it just feels like games are so
volatile it feels weird to think like
that but part of what's made at work is
the singular dedication to a particular
kind of game that is a hybrid a
first-person shooter and RPG like it's a
first-person shooter that doesn't give
you the cinematic thrill ride it lets
you approach things very slowly at your
own pace think about them explore and
that's that guiding principle like
everybody dedicated to that has made it
an amazing fit
come on come on hey you got it I think
it was only a question of time I mean
how could the move the games keep going
trying to emulate movies for it that's
not right to me it's a it feels like
gains are are best at doing what you
just described the best at actually
putting you in a world and where
everything is a simulation and then you
act on it I've been in games 23 years
now and it's like I literally remember
times when executives from publishers
would tell us things like first person
games don't sell or the RPG is dead or
stealth games nobody wants that and it's
always amazing because like at any given
time somebody wants and a large group of
people want almost everything right if
you look at the resurgence of XCOM a
brilliant series the ongoing success of
civilization the elder scrolls just
keeps on rolling you know do you know
being a classic and come back to life
like if you look at those games not all
of it is nostalgia some of is that that
pattern really works it provides a
particular media experience that people
want although they didn't know each
other at the time : Tonio and smith were
both QA testers on system shock the 1994
game from Looking Glass Studios that
would influence a generation of renowned
developers it used overlapping systems
to encourage player choice and
experimentation much like dishonored and
pray today we call this type of game in
immersive sim this was a kind of game :
Tonio wanted to make when he founded
arcane in 1999 but with larger
publishers focusing on sports games and
established franchises plumbing was hard
to find it was here in Austin where ion
storm worked on Deus Ex the legendary
title created under the direction of
Warren Spector it followed in the
footsteps of Looking Glass Studios and
origin systems companies whose games
were deep and complex but never sold
incredibly well in many ways Deus Ex was
the last game from the Golden Age of
immersive Sims
I remember distinctly like loving
first-person action games quite a bit
like I love doom and half-life but I
also still really loved those like
open-ended RPG like games and I like
really wanted somebody to I wanted a
Viking that had both of those things
together when I eventually met Harvey
and was introduced to ion storm and saw
what they were working on Deus Ex it was
like those two things together it's like
somebody somebody had combined peanut
butter and chocolate for me you know to
me and I was like this is the thing I
want this something I'm talking about
but being introduced into that world was
pretty fascinating I came in with you
know I came in with that desire to see
that kind of game that I described but
also came in with some very naive
understandings of like model games do
story better or whatever I don't know
that's still kind of a perennial
question but at the time I thought I had
all the answers already and then I was
like oh this is really hard
it's really hard especially if you want
the player to be telling their own story
instead of creating a movie traces of
immersive Sims can be seen in c3 far cry
2 and the Bioshock series games that
kept this style of game alive after the
closing of ion storm looking left
Studios and origin systems but for the
most part immersive Sims
despite their sophisticated design faded
into the background for almost a decade
and as the members of arcane tell it a
variety of factors played into this dry
period it's just that a lot of
developers get away from them either
because they are they were too hard to
make because too much different
publishers didn't really believe in them
they never worried publishers tend to
have a if you did not tell in the past
it won't sell in the future can I become
the kind of thinking people who don't
have the insider information not about
the industry per se because you have
industry analysts of course but I mean
like about what players feel when they
play these games more touchy-feely some
of the people making those decisions
about funding they don't have that and
so they will come to some conclusion
based on how many copies of farm bill is
from the world or whatever and they'll
make some funding decisions and like
through the gatekeepers it will be hard
to get a project going it is possible
that the older generation of those games
were maybe did not have the amount of
marketing that was needed or the amounts
of of execution that was needed for
truly enjoying those games because
there's a minimum bargaining englishmen
that people now want in order to relieve
and look at your game and that's that's
one of the reasons indie games have
thrived is that people who were in a
position to do so said you know what
we're not going to take money from
anybody we're just going to go live in
my parents house for eight months we're
going to make this game our artist is
going to sleep on the couch and the
spare bedroom is going to be taken by
this programming duo we have and and
they just did it you know so that's why
all these dead genres have have not only
found new life but they're thriving
they've done interesting things they've
moved industry forward after all the
uncertainty of the past decade and the
looming fear that they were in love with
a dead john rrah
dishonored released they crept closer to
a nervous Arkane studios the team has
found trust in publisher Bethesda and
had done their best to explain what
exactly the game was to an audience who
largely forgot what immersive Sims could
be but even so October 9 2012 approached
like a looming cloud all arcane could do
was wait the compelling abilities the
bold artistic design the colorful
characters and above all the freedom of
choice all of these things make
Dishonored a game that demands to be
played and replay
[Music]
but dishonored one was really like our
first breakout for our cane and what I
think led to that was probably all of
the accrued institutional knowledge that
the company had these guys that have
been with us for a very long time and
wrap himself
they had just like worked and worked and
worked on these immersive first-person
games especially with first-person melee
combat and magic and things like that
and blending narrative with AI behaviors
so for Bethesda to go with us and let us
do this thing that has always proven to
not really work out very well
it was actually a pretty bold move that
they appreciate that they had trust in
us to be able to pull off something like
this and make it actually successful it
was a combination of good timing good
team that was finally mature the
publisher that believed in us with the
money that was necessary and the good
marketing eye and understanding of our
game and now we're talking ten years
into the life of the studio and I would
wear a t-shirt with dishonor on it and
people in the airport would stop me and
say oh yeah I've played this game or I
love this game I'm waiting for this game
it was a it was still hard to truly
believe that they were that it was true
that they were sincere because we had
this like job this really habit of being
this just this tiny company they're not
even come close yet to tapping out the
number of people in the world who want
to play a particular kind of game one of
my friends in Austin her mom is
interesting which is 70 and her husband
used to play games together on
university mainframes
back in like the 70s I guess and she
because she knows me she was like I want
to play this game you man Dishonored so
she put it on easy and she had never
played a stealth game and she played
through the entire game trying to avoid
the combat looking at the environments
the pseudo Victorian setting and she
actually finished the game and she had
comments on the lore in the setting and
the environmental storytelling was
really a magical experience and it made
me realize there's a whole audience out
there who could enjoy this type of game
with a few tweaks those car set figures
and shambles
Ivan like for our city two spaces we do
not recognize in many ways the rise of
arcane is tied to the rebirth of
immersive Sims themselves complex games
that aims to reel the player in with
established worlds cohesive rules and
myriad opportunities for emergent
gameplay but the question still remains
why make immersive Sims why not military
shooters or open-world sandbox --is why
devote so much of your life to creating
something that doesn't have a history of
commercial success I'm sure every
developer who makes gains now was
touched at some point by a game that
never left them and that's why do what
they do now and and so in our case it is
the origin / looking last thing like my
first video game experience with
computers anyways I didn't have like a
Nintendo growing up but one day my dad
came home with a Commodore 64 my dad was
in the Air Force of course a lot of the
games we had were simulation games like
gunship like a helicopter mission
simulator but he also brought home some
games like Ultima and the barge tail
like the Barstow first video game I ever
played and ever since then what I liked
best about those games was like the sort
of this is Rp genus of it the feeling of
like I I have some control over my
destiny here you know whether it's like
the character I'm building or the which
way I decide to go explore versus what
somebody else did there's something in
games halfway between
arcade action and strategic play there's
this thing in the middle that feels a
little real time but it's slow enough to
beat at
- cool but underworld came along by
looking glass and it was like a
real-time version of that instead of
moving one square at a time and it was
just magical for people that were we
were already primed for that kind of
game to come out and so when it came out
we were all blown away I think in the
case of those games like underworld
Ultima 7 they were amazing at providing
a sense of place like somewhere that
actually tree exists with it with the it
was built it was crafted in a way that
it was not random rooms or something
everything had a little story they
already had the notion back then of
visual storytelling even though there
was no word for it
so that that's a huge accomplishment you
know that's a lot of work and a lot of
depth and a lot of law in the games a
lot of interesting systems a lot of
principles like looking at what it means
for a game to make you feel like you are
there like if you dig in the trashcan
over in the corner there's a
half-finished note from the guy who's
opposite is that kind of like cohesion
to the world is really powerful
it meets player expectation and then it
defies player expectation it goes
further and and to be fair even now it's
17 meters which is kind of a long time
actually Richard Garrett and you know
what in one year your company would be
as old as origin when we went under so
it's the big deal so after seventeen
years even then we still at least I
still feel like our company is a small
thing you know somehow I still still
trying to to to to get by even though I
know after the acquisition because that
I we have making games now it's much
more it's much easier we have people
where and people know our games but
still we have still this it's not so
because we will start it's more and it's
stay with
[Music]
Looking Glass Studios and origin systems
two names that sound familiar yet for
many playing games today don't ring a
loud Bell but their influence is there
it can be seen in some of the most
influential games in the medium projects
such as Bioshock half life and even the
Xbox itself Oh their existence two
people who worked at these seminal
companies before they closed if you pay
close attention you'll notice the number
zero four five one in a handful of video
games it unlocks a door and pray it
opens a safe in Dishonored 2 it grants
you access to a filing cabinet in gone
home and back in the 90s it unlocked the
actual real world front door 2 Looking
Glass Studios it's a reference to Ray
Bradbury's Fahrenheit 451 a book about
preserving culture in a way of thinking
against all odds to understand where
immersive Sims are now and how they're
shaping the entire medium it's crucial
to understand where they've been because
in many ways the story of Arkane Studios
isn't complete without tracing it back
to its influences back to the people who
created immersive Sims in the first
place back to the people who mentored
Smith : Tonio & Behr when they were
first beginning as developers and as
luck would have it two such legends are
still making games today and as luck
would have it they live right down the
road
[Music]